bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon tout sur les échecs et aujourd'hui
leçon spéciale consacrée à l'ouverture
s'il ya un âge d'or avec comme
intervenants jean luc shahbanou le grand
maître international bonjour jean luc
bonjour est loin
la sicilienne nash dehors c'est une arme
très tranchante joués par les plus
grands champions de la planète puisque c
est l arme favorite de bobby fischer
c'est aujourd'hui l'ouverture que
kasparov utilisent en permanence
sept matchs de horse première question
jean luc d'où ça vient d'où vient ce nom
la défense major donc comme beaucoup
d'ouverture aux échecs la défense à
nador fait une ouverture qui doit son
nom à un joueur d'échecs donc un joueur
argentin miguel nador qui était qui
était donc le meilleur joueur sud
américain de ce début de siècle et qui
est mort il ya quelques années donc mis
guen hd offre une star nationale en
argentine et qui donc a inventé cette
ouverture
il a inventé la mise au point il a
développé la améliorer donc c'est sa
part d'une sicilienne normal c'est
normal on vous montrera tout à l'heure
ce que c'est pour décrire cette
ouverture avec quelques adjectifs
lesquels sur lesquels choisirais tu on
va dire que c'est à à la fois une
ouverture extrêmement solide puisqu'on
doit qu on doit constater que en
compétition les joueurs avec les noirs
donc perdre très peu de parties une
ouverture très logique qui contrôle le
centre et en même temps une arme
extrêmement dangereuse une arme de
contre attaque qui qui est très
redoutable puisque c'est quand même joué
par le par le king garry kasparov
actuellement qui est des très bons
résultats avec on le notera nous allons
donc aujourd'hui essayer de vous
expliquer cette ouverture un âge d'or
c'est une introduction donc nous allons
parler un peu de toutes les possibilités
des blancs pour lutter contre cette
défense nador une seule condition pour
jouer d'un âge d'or ou en tout cas pour
jouer la sicilienne votre adversaire de
jouer le coup un e 4 sinon il n'y a pas
de cécilienne et ensuite on verra
toutes les déviations des blancs pour
éviter la nage dorff une fois que les
jouets ou 4 et ensuite nous arrivons
évidemment dans les grandes lignes de la
neige d'or donc nous allons
montrer tout ça c'est un petit peu une
vue d'ensemble de l'ouverture nalcor que
nous vous proposons aujourd'hui alors
tout de suite on va maquiller chéquier
le voilà premier coup les blancs jouent
eux deux quatre et les noirs jouent ces
cinq sages jean-luc seles et céline
voilà donc c'est compliqué analyse la
sicilienne les noirs qui qui ne jouent
pas symétriques mais qui contrôle quand
même la case centrale d2 d4 par le coup
c'est cette c5 et ce genre de position
mais n'a finalement à des positions un
peu plus un peu plus complexe que 4,5
puisque puisque on arrivera probablement
une asymétrie au niveau de la chaîne de
pions première voie ma première idée de
cette ouverture sicilienne c'est que les
blancs ne peuvent pas donc installer un
duo thion centrale puisque s'il joue des
quatre tout de suite on prend en d4
on verra que ça existe c'est le fameux
gang qui n'aura que nous avons déjà
traité dans diagonale mais là pour voir
pour en savoir plus sur le banc guy
morin et bien je vous invite à aller
dans la rubrique des ouvertures jouer un
veau 4 avec les blancs et durera une
analyse du gambit mora ici donc les
blancs dans cette position en plusieurs
points
il ya des systèmes qu'on appelle anti
sicilienne oui plusieurs systèmes dans
cette position il y a donc la sicilienne
fermé pour commencer à une cave et
laissé trois cavaliers c3 alors on
appelle ça sicilienne fermé parce que
les blancs ne joueront vraisemblablement
pas avec des quatre mais ils se
contenteront de mettre leurs pions sur
la case d3 voilà donc les blancs qui
vont jouer probablement détroit et le
plonger et elles vont le pousser donc en
g3 pour mettre leurs fous blanc ancien
ghetto en g2 donc dans dans ce type de
position
on doit dire que les blancs recherche
finalement une position de type est
indienne avec les blancs une sorte de
weeds indienne joué en premier joué en
premier voilà donc la bonne façon de
région avec les noirs contre ce coup
qu'avec ces trois là façon principale je
crois que c'est de jouer cavalier c6
déjà suivi de gsm g6 on va jouer et très
très souvent quand les blancs refuse le
débat théorique et je ne joue donc pas
cavalier f3 et des quatre qui sont les
coûts principaux qui caractérise la
société ouverte et bien très
régulièrement on fera appel à cette
formation
quel c6 v6 est fou g71 fonction kétou
pour contrôler très bien les cases
noires au centre de l'échiquier
ça c'est l'une des idées principales des
noirs dès que les blancs ne veulent pas
jouer avec des quatre on lit ça c'est
l'idée principale donc contrôler le
centre et en attendant donc les blancs
eux essaieront de pousser leurs pions
est fait de lancer une attaque allait le
roi c'est un petit peu compliqué il y
aura également un traité dans cette
ouverture l'attaquent grand prix qui se
joue à f4 cavalière 3 donc ça nous
ferons
des émissions spécialement dédié à ces
systèmes anti sicilienne comme on peut
les appeler
oui autre possibilité au deuxième où
jean-luc il ya une autre variante qui
est vraiment très importante ou c2 c3
donc la variante à la pine de la
sicilienne voilà donc une variante assez
logique également donc un petit peu
comme comme le préconise et finalement
au nimh dovic début du siècle on arrive
on peut arriver dans des positions de
6,2 française variante avance donc
toujours jouer pour sa structure de
pions mais si le coût principal gong c3
l'idée est très simple jean luc c'est de
jouer des 4es de reprendre du pillon et
quand les noirs prennent on reprend avec
le pion et pour ça les bleus ont trouvé
les noirs ont trouvé une solution que
nous allons que nous étudions plus tard
c'est qu'il joue dans cette question de
coût 17 des cinq tout de suite qui fait
donc une sorte de scandinaves mais avec
les coûts ces cinq essais 3 intercalé
c'est donc pas du tout pareil et ça on
vous expliquera bien comment jouer mais
en général ça amène des positions où les
blancs et un pion isolé juste mentionné
cette petite variante on reprend de la
dame
les blanches des quatre est dans cette
position est bien content repris en d4
les blancs reprendront du pion ont pas
forcément tout de suite en d4 il ya une
position actuelle isolé il y aura
évidemment une émission entière
consacrée à ce thème la cécilienne c3 la
fameuse variante à la pine autre
variante l'onudc donc sur e4 c'est ça
qu'il y a donc plusieurs variantes
secondaire il veut je pense qu'il faut
quand même passé à cavalier f3
maintenant cavalier f3c le coût
principal dans cette position tous les
grands joueurs jo cavaliers f3 ils ont
pratiquement tous arrêter d'essayer des
sous systèmes pour lutter contre la
sicilienne il faut vraisemblablement
jouer ce coup dans cette position l'idée
j'en ai assez de jouer des 4 et quand
les blancs les noirs prennent on reprend
avec lecavalier et donc on installe un
cas lié aux cendres
évidemment donc cavalier f3 qui est plus
intéressant que des cas tout de suite
puisque si on jouait des 4 as
directement dans cette position qui on
prend des quatre dames prend des cats si
on voulait reprendre avec une pièce on
ne respecte pas les règles du jeu
d'échecs cclat dans cette position les
soirs on respecte les règles du jeu
d'échecs où est ben pas les règles
les règles
ils ont pas les principes et la lettre
et incitera les principes donc après
cavaliers des huit c6 lecavalier en c6
chasse la dame de cette case centrale
donc la date doit jouer à nouveau et les
noirs se retrouve à nouveau au trait et
ont gagné finalement un gros tempo les
noms en gagner énormément de temps c'est
pour ça que les blancs dans cette
question de jouer cavalier f3 elles ne
veulent pas reprendre avec la dame en d4
et la major dans cette position c'est un
coût qui est assez curieux puisque on ne
sort pas de pièce on joue simplement le
17 des six
oui donc on commence par le coût 17 des
six on laisse plein de souplesse à la
position noir et donc l'idée principale
c'est c'est tout simplement de laisser
jouer les longues de laisser jouer les
blancs de laisser les blancs occuper le
centre on ne veut pas sortir ce cavalier
b8 oui c'était le coût principal
finalement cavaliers c6 on ne veut pas
jouer qui laissait 6 dans cette position
puisque on veut garder un maximum de
souplesse pour avoir les possibilités de
le mettre en des scènes dans certains
cas exactement
donc exactement je change d'attitude
donc finalement pourra plus de souplesse
à l'el dames puisque dans ce genre
d'ouverture beaucoup de choses se
passent à la dame ici après qu'edf trois
des six donc un coût tout en souplesse
et c'est toute l'idée de la nage dorff
la souplesse les blancs donc peuvent
jouer des cats et le coût principal
qu'on regardera tout à l'heure mais il y
a deux autres alternatives extrêmement
jouer jean luc voilà il ya deux autres
alternatives est extrêmement jouer on va
commencer par la moins importante c'est
c2 c3 c2 c3 donc donc c'est encore la
même idée qu avant sauf que là justement
si on se réfère par analogie donc on va
jouer des 4es reprendre avec le pion est
bien ici les noirs ne peuvent plus jouer
des 5
oui ça change un tout petit peu donc par
rapport à tout à l'heure et là je crois
que le principal ses cavaliers f6
effectivement qu'isis donc tout
simplement attaqué le pion central est
une manoeuvre un peu curieuse bête
classique c'est quand même de jouer
cloud food et 3 je crois et l'allemagne
a plusieurs solutions pour les blancs
dans 7 milliards grillage ainsi dans
cette position peut jouer le coup h3 par
exemple voilà puisque sûr qu'ils
allaient prendre quatre ans ou damas
quatre échecs qui récupère le cavalier
donc ce qu'il faut voir c'est que l'idée
de ce coup qu'avec des petits seins le
moyen pour vous en rappeler c'est qu'on
ne veut pas prendre l'option de 4
puisqu'il n'est pas attaqué nous on veut
éviter que les blanches ou des quatre
puisque si je vous dis qu'après bien
voilà damas quatre échecs ne marche plus
donc voila un petit peu l'idée de ce
conte cavalia 2 6 et sur n'importe
quelle réponse planches à part des
quatre au coude apprend que jouer câble
et b17 qui cette fois-ci attaquera
vraiment le pion et empêchera les blancs
justement de jouer le fameux des deux
des quatre ont un seul coup faudra
qu'ils retardent ça mais enfin cette
ouverture c3 est assez des liseuses
il faut s'y préparer et donc être prêt à
jouer les bons émission évidemment qui
sera dédiée à cette souriante de la
sienne l'âge d'or encore une oui on peut
dire que là c'est le moment où les
blancs dispose de ces deux armes donc
ces trois et le coup qu'on va voir
actuellement donc fougue et 5
donc c'est au moment où il est blanc
dispose de deux armes qui sont assez
dangereuse et qui pose quelques
problèmes au noir actuellement même si
sa tendance quand même en général a
amené à des positions assez assez
équilibré pour contrer cet échec en
bessin nous jouons naturellement fou 17
et après le foot rend fou on va vous
montrer la variante four en fout on
reprendre la dame puisque c'est très
important de mettre le camion de ses six
maintenant les blancs peuvent s est
jouée avec ses trois plus des quatre ils
peuvent essayer plusieurs choses
ils peuvent jouer avec détroit rossi il
ya plusieurs possibilités mais cette
ouverture n'est pas très dangereuse le
développement naturel pour les noirs
après ça va être cassée six cavaliers m6
2,6 fawcett avec une position
extrêmement solide jean-luc une position
extrêmement solide évidemment c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'avait choisi garry
kasparov quand il a joué sa partie
contre le reste du monde
une partie qui s'est jouée ya vingt et
un ans match organisé sur internet on le
rappelle dans cette position après des
six il ya donc floue b5 échec qui n'est
pas très dangereux
il ya ces trois qui n'est pas très
dangereux non plus le coût principal
on l'a déjà dit jean-luc c'est le coût
des deux des quatre voilà donc des deux
des quatre on décide d'ouvrir le débat
pion préemption du champion c'est toute
l'idée des noirs cavaliers prend pions
qu'avec des champions là les noirs joue
cavalier f6 cavaliers six attaquants le
pion aux caprins champions est en prison
maintenant avec ça c'est à dire
franchement quels vis à vis maintenant
on évite que les blancs puisse jouer ces
deux c4 et ensuite calé ses trois en
attaquant tout de suite le pion en 4 et
bien on oblige pratiquement les blancs à
jouer cavalier c3 ont ils à
l'alternative f2 f3 mais cavaliers c3 et
le coût principal f2 f3 c'est vrai que
il faut absolument traiter ça c'est une
idée complètement différente c'est de
jouer avec ses 4 c'est pas vraiment une
ccn ouverte c'est plutôt ça peut
apparenter cette possibilité au zoom aux
variantes qui amène vers 1 et au delà
roxy oui c'est ce qu'on pourrait
rechercher donc avec les blancs une
position avec un maximum de contrôle du
centre et pion central dans le 4 e cat
et c4 qui contrôle bien qu'ils
verrouillent la casse des cinq ont mais
bon dans cet ordre de koussa laisse
quand même au noir plusieurs
possibilités pour pour contre attaquer
tout à fait donc avalé ses droits voilà
qui avait laissé 3 ici il ya plusieurs
plein de possibilités pour les noirs il
ya là cécile sicilienne du dragon voilà
c'est lui que j'ai 6 la ccit mènera aux
heures ses coûts qu'elle et ses 6 mai
lan âge d'or c'est pas ça jean luc non
le cookie caractère ici et qui
caractérise cette défense nach den hove
c'est le coût à 7 à 6 voilà donc à 7 à 6
un coup très très intéressant donc
encore une fois les noirs ne veulent pas
ne veulent pas jouer c'est un poumon
tout en souplesse exactement donc les
noirs ne veulent pas prendre de décision
immédiate et il ne veut pas surtout
sortir ce cavalier b8 il préfère
regarder donc la colonne la colonne
s'est ouverte pour l'instant voilà
et évidemment il s'apprête aussi à jouer
le coup dans cette position
principalement le coup eux 7 5 7 5
et de temps en temps 17 des 5 voilà et
de tomber cette décharge fait
parfaitement parti de toutes les
possibilités dans la neige d'or que dire
de plus les sept dessins qui permettrait
éventuellement d'attaqués depuis on a eu
quatre par le coup b5 bekkat un des
plans très fréquent dans un âge d'or fin
normalement on va jouer au cices aux
seins qui bouge ça ça dépend
on va jouer b5 après on me nostra dont
des quatre qui chasse le cas et c'est 3
ea tacle sur quatre le fou on le mettra
sur la case bessette lecavalier
on mettra sur la case 17 puis
éventuellement c'est simple il a tout un
jeu de pièces qui est axé autour de la
taxe sur le pion aux quatre oui et sur
les quatre centrales évidemment sur
toutes les quatre centrales dans cette
position jean luc c'est vraiment le
moment critique les blancs ont quatre
coups qui sont vraiment très dangereux
et très différents les uns des autres on
va les détaillants ben oui on va donc
s'intéresser à ces quatre coups donc on
va peut-être commencer par les coups ou
les blancs ont font petit rock en
général oui
donc on va commencer par le coup
un vieux coup le couffo 2 donc vieux
couffouleux 2 donc là les blancs ont un
plan simple c'est tout simplement de
faire petit rock f2f 4 x 3 et airois
chat par exemple et ensuite on voit et
ensuite on voit ce qu'on fait tout à
fait alors sur fou aux deux on joue la
variante avec le site variante très
calme on laisse faire les blancs chacun
des deux camps va se développer et on
arrivera à une position tout à fait
classique la pression scheveningen qui a
fait l'objet de nombreux débats
théoriques entre karpov et kasparov
oui donc faux et de une variante qui
était extrêmement à la mode dans les
années 80 et qui qui se joue un peu
moins actuellement on va dire que ça se
joue dans les moments les moins
importants dans les matchs lorsque les
décisions sont faites et qu'on veut
concrétiser son avantage ou ou dans une
dans une phase d'observation
mais ce n'est pas la marne que l'on sort
lorsqu on a vraiment envie de marquer
encore débarquer un point fouilles 2
c'est une variante donc très très souple
à vocation pas très dangereuse donc les
blancs ne prennent pas trop de risques
mais en même temps se ferme beaucoup
d'opportunités de gains on joue donc le
cou aux 6 mettons que les blancs jouent
petit rock dans cette position c'est
logique
maintenant on sort le fou sur la case
aux 7es ici si les blancs jouent f4 et
bien ne pouvons jouer des cinq aux
menaces b5 à partir de maintenant donc
vraisemblablement donc il ya beaucoup de
subtilité dans cette position les blancs
peuvent jouer fouet 3f cape may avait
cinq dont il préfère jouer le coup à
deux à quatre très très logique pour
empêcher complètement le contrôle des
noirs à base de baies 5 dans cette
position pas de panique pour les noirs
on a un plan de développement qui est
tout à fait déterminé on joue petit rock
les blanches par exemple fou 3 et là on
ne met pas le cavalier en 17 jean luc ça
serait assez malvenues dans cette
position parce que les blancs percevrait
en jouant f4 f5 avec une attaque
dangereuse
il faut mettre le cavaly sur la case c6
et après f4 non menace peut-être calais
processes suivi 2 5 il faut donc se
méfier jouer dame ses sets et après le
court à agen
les noirs ont énormément de possibilités
c'est là c'est là vraiment la position
scheveningen tout à fait classique
ici on peut jouer tour au but on peut
retourner vite on peut je me fous des
sept
il ya beaucoup de solutions c'est une
position complexe une position très
complexe donc on voit que d'une manière
générale donc les blancs ont plus d
espace dans cette position mais les
noirs contrôle très très bien toutes les
cases les cases centrale la colonne
s'est ouverte pour les noirs donc là les
noirs exerce une pression donc contre ce
manque d'espacé ils ont quand même cette
pression allèles dame qui est très
intéressante et si les blancs veulent
obtenir beaucoup des taxes sur le roi
noir
il va falloir pousser éventuellement le
plonger ce qui en même ce qui serait
très dangereux puisqu'on pourrait jouer
g4 g5 chasser ce cavalier de f6 une case
pour cavaliers contrôler les quatre
centrales mais en même temps il y aurait
quelques inconvénients puisque on voit
qu'après avoir que c'est le plonger le
roi blanc se retrouverait un petit peu a
découvert sur la grande diagonale
notamment effectivement ici c'est donc
une position assez tranchantes quand
même que les blancs peuvent traiter
d'une façon
beaucoup plus sécurisée en ne faisant
tout simplement rien dire qu'il joue par
exemple ou f3 dam des deux tours d un si
les banques font rien dans cette
position c'est pas facile pour le nord
de passer mais il existe des solutions
ici on même si les banques veulent faire
nul on peut pas dire encore qu'ils aient
réussi donc c'est une position qui est
extrêmement souple est qui et qui laisse
d'énormes possibilités aux deux camps
donc contre ce coup faut 2 on va revenir
à la position de départ c'est celle-là à
6 selanne âge d'or donc nous allons
enlever quand même toutes ses flèches
qui sont un petit peu parasitaire il
faut bien le dire
voilà cette question d'âge d'or première
possibilité des blancs c'est fou aux
deux là les noirs jouent avec eux 6
c'est assez important
ensuite ils sortent leur pièce fawcett
il met le cavalier bits sur la case c6
jean-luc il faudra le mettre en cécile
contre quand on veut jouer contre faut 2
oui ça c'est le genre de chose dont il
faut se rappeler
autre possibilité donc toujours les
blancs jouerait des plans avec petit
rock voilà donc on va prendre le coup
ces quatre fous ces quatre un coût qui
revient de temps en temps à la mode et
qui est quand même un petit peu plus
agressif que fo et 2 puisque souvent
dans cette position il faut faire très
attention à ce fou de cases blanches qui
est placé sur la diagonale
à 2 g 8 voilà donc l'idée préfou sekkat
jeu c'est de jouer de 7,6 pour les noirs
donc un petit rock pour les blancs petit
rock alors a noté jean luc dans cette
position les blancs peuvent aussi jouer
avec flo 3d modeuses et et grandes et
grands
donc ça c'est une variante que fisher
affectionnait particulièrement
c'est la taxe aux in des lignes which
was in fous ces quatre avec l'idée qu'en
rock ça existe mais généralement joue
plutôt avec l'idée petit rock et f4 f5
et f4 f5 voilà donc on essaye finalement
donc d'affaiblir le la case e6 avec f4
f5 et c'est beaucoup plus concret
qu'avec un fou en e2 dans cette position
cette attaque de plus en plus qu'il ya
un fou en c4 qui qui qui est sur cette
diagonale il cavaliere des quatre qui
attaquent la case de 6,6 le pion à eux
après f4 f5 avance sur la case de 5 dans
ces cas là les noirs abandonnerait donc
la grande diagonale pour le fouet la
case des cinq contre trois pour le
cavalier c3 dans ce contexte là ce ne
serait pas
très intéressant pour les noirs il faut
donc se prémunir contre cette poussée f4
f5 du meilleur moyen possible et pour ça
les noirs ont trouvé une solution assez
récemment
mis à jour par anand donc bessette b5
rb5 four b3 et dans cette position le
simple qufu 17 très curieux pour jouer
qu'avec ses 6 après échange et un
cavalier et jouer avec fawcett
on peut également jouer avec b4 très
très souvent oui donc bekkat un coût qui
était la bonne ce qui est toujours une
menace dans ce type de position il ya
pas mal de fois où le sacrifice n'est
pas bon le sacré des options e 4 mais
quelquefois le pion est véritablement
emprise il faut s'en méfier tout à fait
donc ici les blancs peuvent jouer avec
f4 c'est un sacrifice de pions ils
peuvent jouer avec tout rond en ce
moment ils n'ont pas grand chose mais ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que dans cette
variante avec fu c4 et bien les noirs
doivent réagir très vite pour ne pas se
faire massacrer positionnement par le
bélier f4 f5
donc ça c'est une variante assez
dangereuse ou c4
il faut savoir la traite avec précision
et c'est ce qu'on vous montrera
évidemment dans l'émission consacrée à
ce coup ci ce fou ces quatre autres
possibilités jean-luc donc les
possibilités avec petit rock il y en
aura une troisième quand on pourrait
mentionner donc c'est le coup f2f 4 donc
ça c'est une variante un peu plus
mineures elle est pas beaucoup joué en
moyenne 26 a été jouée à tout petit peu
il ya quelques années par entre autres
par michael adams mai mais qui
finalement
qui n'a pas donné de suite donc on joue
dans cette position aurait agi par sept
le 5 7 5 est aussi une possibilité qui
est tous âges et 6 transposant dans une
dragon plutôt bonne configuration pour
les noirs mais aux 7,5 et le coût
considéré comme étant le meilleur
voilà donc le terrain et de l'eau
revient sur la case f3 roi maintenant on
joue je crois le couffo sept ans tout
simplement on menace de jouer b5 les
blancs jouent on se fait avec à 4 et
maintenant plusieurs possibilités on m
avait dit [ __ ] en 17 ans et 6 jean-luc
dans cette position je crois qu'on peu
rauque et directement on peut rock est
d'abord peu d'avoir ok le le fou vient
sur la case d3 3 et le cavalier ans et 6
km entre 6 et ici il ya une variante
très très importante sur petit rock et
bien nous prônons le pion au f4 puisque
sur flu point f4 il vient fou g4 il y
avait six échecs et d'un pro d2 ah oui
désolé jean le moindre jeu roi agenda on
joue donc gros achats et maintenant il
ya multiples possibilités où vous en
dira plus dans cette position elle n'est
pas très dangereuse les noirs doivent
juste faire attention au début puisque
il faut prendre f4 au bon moment là
toute la difficulté et la série si on
laisse jouer les blancs et qu'ils
arrivent à prendre en 1 5
ensuite tout est fou j'ai 5 eca et
dessins qu'il peut y avoir des problèmes
mais on ne laisse pas faire ça il faut
prendre avec 4 au bon moment c'est c'est
bien connu et beaucoup de théorie
là-dessus on vous en expliquera plus
tout à l'heure c'est encore une variante
f24 au sixième trou où les noirs de
jouer très précisément dès le départ ah
oui donc dans le le problème donc de
cette nage dorff
s'il ya un problème c'est que les noirs
doivent maîtriser donc doivent connaître
les
et les suites de coups au début très
très exactement parce qu'ils y aillent à
d'énormes dangers mais des couvertures
et bien négocié après c'est un c'est un
régal et on verra qu'on l'assimilé assez
facilement puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se ressemblent beaucoup de
plans communs dans toutes ses variantes
et une fois que vous serez bien les
jouer et bien vous serez prêt à
l'affronter plus ou moins n'importe qui
puisque la réputation d'un âge d'or n'a
pas encore été trouvé il ya une
tentative extrêmement dangereuse contre
la nature jean luc oui donc la tentative
une des tentatives les plus dangereuses
de contre un adjoint pc arrive aux deux
plus dangereux voilà donc c'est le coup
j'ai 5 voilà donc le couffo g5 ou g5 qui
a été jouée par tous les plus forts
joueurs qui ont dû affronter la neige
d'or fin juin exactement et c'est le
cookie qui est un des coups les plus
historiques dans cette variante
puisqu'il donne à lille donne lieu à
cette fameuse variante du pion
empoisonné tu empoisonné il ya plusieurs
possibilités il ya aussi la fameuse
veyron toulouse gueddafi
si on joue non ce n'est pas un essai au
cices d'abord de toute façon le 6
d'abord f2f 4 et ios 4 et 7 des sa voix
ça c'est la vente plus gately qu'on ne
va pas regarder parce qu'elle est
vraiment trop douteuses la légende dit
que paul hogan ce qui arrive à la joue
et tous les autres se faisant tout
simplement pulvérisé il ya la variante
laurent frayssinet tony kosten et donc
le qooq est blessé si ce qui est
intéressant mais pas très bon et le coût
principal celui qu on s'efforcera
d'étudier c'est l'option empoisonné avec
d'albé six mois et donc d'un v6 et là on
peut donc donner le pion par dame c'est
leur corps en fait les si on revient en
juin kébé 3 avec les blancs on obtient
une position sicilienne à peu près
normale ou les noirs n'ont pas de
problème pas vraiment de problème
puisque l'on joue et qui a aidé trois
donc le sacrifice de pioncer dam des
deux dates des deux dames prend b2 dame
prend b2 donc on prend un ton très
important parce qu'en plus les blancs ne
peuvent plus faire le vendre maintenant
mais d'un autre côté après tour b 1
damas 3 on voit qu'il est noir perdre
énormément de temps où il est blanc
développe et donc leur tour les deux
cavaliers sont bien placés le fou est
bien placé le centre de pions existe
c'est quand même une position
extrêmement csu dangereux c'est super
dangereux mais gary kasparov n'a jamais
perdu cette position effectivement on
n'est pas garry kasparov mais nos
adversaires ne sont pas non plus les
mêmes que les siens donc on peut espérer
dans cette position gagné beaucoup de
parties en revanche l'inconvénient c'est
que les blancs ont des possibilités pour
faire nul de manière forcée ils peuvent
tout à fait répéter les coups très
régulièrement dans diverses situations
un des coups dangereux ici c'est le coup
f5 tout de suite je crois il ya
également fout d'eux donc évidemment ça
devant des quatre pions sera traitée
bien en détail mais elle est trop
compliquée pour être expliquer en
quelques instants
sachez simplement que dame b6 est sans
doute le bon coup pour réagir à fou j'ai
cinq derniers couvrent jean-luc d'un
appareil en temps voilà donc on va
passer finalement à la variante qui est
à la mode actuellement
donc le couffo c1 à eux trois un coup
donc qui se caractérise donc par une
attaque de type saint-georges si on peut
l'appeler comme ça c'est à dire qu'on
veut jouer f2 f3 g2g 4 mètres la dame en
d2 et fernand roques et attaquer le roi
noir donc qui est qui qui va se
retrouver du petit côté plusieurs
solutions pour lutter contre le couffo à
3 soit en jouant avec eux 6 ce qui
serait très dangereux
est-ce que garry kasparov et très bien
on lit dans caritas harkis qui lui
préfèrent eux 6 mai qui joue également
au 6 7 5
gary considère faire dans cette position
les deux coups son possible pour les
noirs au sein que c'est pas mal non plus
mais c'est très compliqué donc nous nous
allons étudier plus tôt le coup eux six
maintenant les blancs jouent en général
f3 on joue cavalier e bay 5 dam des deux
fous bessette et là c'est très très
important sur grand roque on joue le
coût des quatre on force le cavalier à
partir et on joue la percée central des
six des 5 avec une position très très
complexe à on y reviendra dans faut 3 un
chapitre dédié encore dans cette si elle
adore donc jean luc la nage d'or c'est
très compliqué il faut bien connaître
mais on obtient des résultats assez
fracassant on voit que dans toutes les
positions les noirs ont beaucoup de
l'eau elle est noire dont utilise une
stratégie très ambitieuse et finalement
donc c'est une arme a conseillé pour
pour les amateurs on vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette émission diagonale
la leçon on vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour donc toujours la
défense nador mais plus précisément et
donc à bientôt
lee